now let's review the model and view in a
bit more detail the model is going to be
super simple it's just our data at array
of cat objects with properties for name
click count and image URL nothing new
here now the view well actually if we
want to we can split this up into two
views first we have the list of cats and
second we have the cat viewing area both
of these views will be pretty simple
they'll just have render functions that
redraw the respective areas and they'll
have click handle is registered for the
various cats up here and for the image
down here now why am I splitting them up
into two views well here's a good way to
think about this think about how
separate they are functionally not with
regard to action but with regard to what
gets rendered the list renders a list of
cats when does this rear ender well
right now it only renders one time at
the start of the application this other
part renders cat details and it gets
rear-ended every single time you click
on the cat now they're both separate
visually and in terms of when they get
rendered separation does make some sense
here now if you wanted to make them one
view that would work just fine but it's
generally a good idea to separate out
functionality into smaller chunks
whenever it's possible